talk
that uh would be presenting the amish
logic platform
uh we will have uh
two
persons that will be speaking today to
us
allow me to introduce them
i am happy to introduce the ceo of pine
biotech
uh mr elia broski he is one of the
co-founders of the pion biotech company
elia's background is in is in applied
mathematics and data sign
he is currently completing his degree in
business and management from tulane
university
he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
istanbul
louisiana state university tulane and
other academic and pharma rmb teams
mr broski oversees the strategic
development of research projects and
manages the teams responsible for
bioinformatics analysis training and
collaborations for time biotech
has over 12 years of experience in and
in research and industry
he completed a master's in
bioinformatics from jamia media islamia
and a phd in computational biology and
chemistry
from
jawan haral nehru university he is an
expert in machine learning application
to biomedical and chemical data he is
currently heading the global business
development for time biotech
usa and contributing to bioinformatic
research and education by collaborating
with universities in india and africa
and mentoring participants from various
programs by providing bioinformatic
research supporting applying statistical
and algorithmic approaches
we thank
the
sponsors uh for this activity puerto
rico
uh university of puerto rico medical
francis campus and maybe amex logic
pr inbre and the talbot bioinformatics
research center
please like it proceed
okay thank you very much for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
having us today
i want to start by briefly
sharing
some background information about nepi
for those of you that are not familiar
nepi is the national association of idea
principal investigators
and as a part of this organization
it connects the idea community so the
idea community
are the um
states
23 states including puerto rico
that are funded through the nih to
elevate the level of biomedical research
and you can find some more information
about this
organization on the website nappy.org
and i'm
thank you
and i'm
here
presenting today's
session
on behalf of nepy essentially because
some of the materials and resources that
we will cover today are being offered
through nepe
and so to briefly explain uh what nepy's
objective is in this program
i will also share maybe a link or just
if you could share the link to the nepe
website
that explains
essentially what our program is designed
to achieve
which is provide training and link
resources across this network to offer
elevated access to biomedical research
using computational tools and
okay let bioinformatics
start my presentation
okay so what i want to share with you
today is uh the project-based training
in bioinformatics and data science
that we have designed to address a gap
in skills and the resources that we
think exists
across these 23 states and puerto rico
primarily starting from the
undergraduate level and offered as an
integrated path from learning to
research
and so before we begin
talking about what exactly this program
includes i want to introduce you to a
portal that we designed to
make sure that these resources are
widely accessible and effective
using our asynchronous portal called
omixlogic so if you please go to
learn.omicslogic.com
and i believe that the link to the
portal will also be available in the
chat
you will find here that uh you know we
explain kind of what this portal is all
about biology as a data science on the
front page and i will walk you today
through some of the resources that this
portal includes and how this activity
can be used for training and preparation
of students for research activity using
bioinformatics and computational biology
and then later on i will pass it on to
dr mohit mazumdar who will speak about
some of the ongoing programs that we
currently have offered through the
louisiana biomedical research network
and now being available to the nepe
community
as well as some of the upcoming events
and resources that are scheduled for the
spring and the summer of 2022.
so if anyone wants to understand how
this portal works it's always useful to
start with creating a profile
so you will see that there's a login
button and it's very easy to create an
account and so i will encourage you to
just try it out yourself right now if
you can go and create an account
right here as you click on sign in it's
a free sign in
you then create an account by clicking
this button and the first thing that you
will see is that everything that we will
be discussing today is focused on that
user profile so you'll be able to see
how this portal works and i will
introduce some of the elements that we
use in training for different types of
omics data analysis and data science
so
once you log in
you will notice
that there is going to be a user profile
so right here on the top you will find
your email address
and in that email address you will find
all of this activity related to your
user profile and we use this information
in part to validate that the user
participants are a part of the nepe
network because for them all of this
training is available for free
throughout 2022
so i'll give you just a moment here to
sign in and i will switch over
to
my own account just to illustrate how
this works
okay so learn
linuxlogic.com
if i log out you will see right here on
top of the screen you will see a login
button
and here you can create an account
and you can either use your email and
create a password
or
you can sign in with one of your social
media accounts
so i already have an account i'm going
to just sign in
and after you're signed in you will be
redirected to either
different levels of access
so you can skip that uh or uh to this
part of the portal that lists out the
different coursework that we have so
today i'll briefly introduce some of
these resources but i wanted to start
from this overview of your account
so on this account
you will find your personal activity
and certification as you complete some
of the coursework
so what we've realized uh working with
the louisiana biomedical research
network as well as with other states is
that expertise in bioinformatics is
really
not distributed equitably or equally
throughout the different regions where
we interact with students in fact what
we've noticed is that there's a big gap
in even understanding of the role of
bioinformatics and data science in many
aspects of biomedical research
and the challenge i think is that we
don't introduce these concepts early
enough
in the uh kind of horizons of the
students that are joining
research projects and so as a result
there's a gap in skills when those
students want to participate in
meaningful research you want to involve
them in a research study in a grant
proposal or collaboration
they are not equipped to deal with data
and so to introduce different aspects of
skills
including technical skills as well as
conceptual skills or what we call the
logic behind omix data we've designed
this portal that seeks to address the
gap in in skills and the understanding
of how biomedical data could be analyzed
to produce meaningful insights and one
of the things that we are
working on is a certification
provided through regional as well as
local institutions for example
lbrn the louisiana biomedical research
network would be a research a regional
institution and lsu louisiana state
university would be a local entity
they can provide training certificates
that validate that the student is ready
or a researcher essentially is ready to
participate in
all aspects of research that include
bioinformatics one of the ways that we
do this is through our tracking system
that looks at different aspects of
participation activity and skill sets
that are covered in the different topics
that are introduced throughout the
portal an important component of that is
a project so a lot of times
when we try to understand if a student
is ready to participate in a project
it's not enough to just have basic
skills like coding in r or statistical
analysis what we really want to
understand is whether a student is ready
to understand the question the research
question and the approach that could be
taken using data to address that
question and so a big part of what we
are trying to do is design a system that
leads from basic training which is skill
based training to
research based training which is project
oriented and so this project process
that we've designed here starts from
completing your profile and presenting
yourself to the world that goes to
earning a certain number of points which
validates that you have the technical
skills and then eventually it gives you
access to a specific course
that addresses common uh challenges that
people face in designing and developing
an independent project using
bioinformatics and computational biology
tools
so as a result
what we see is that those students that
are able to complete a project and here
we have
sorry i'll go back to here here we have
an example of what this project
structure looks like you can see that it
actually prepares a student to think
about their research presentation for a
poster session or even a publication and
i think that's really a critical need
that we all face in
giving access to research projects and
involving students especially
undergraduate students in biomedical
research that is ongoing right we want
them to understand the format we want
them to understand reproducibility of
research and we want them to be able to
describe the methodology and the
approaches that they take in technical
uh language that is uh you know brief
and and something that we can all review
so that is an essential part of the
training that we provide
and
to be able to get to that level to be
able to address
kind of the place where students
commonly are when they begin this
training and where they should be when
we anticipate them to be ready to
participate in meaningful research we
provide a curriculum
that is organized by several different
subjects so first of all we have
different topics that we cover including
methods of analysis for example
statistical analysis on machine learning
types of data genomics transcriptomics
epigenomics and metagenomics as well as
different levels for example getting
started or trying to address a skill in
r coding or python coding and eventually
getting into a project and projects here
refer to publications that are digested
curated data sets from that publication
are extracted and reproducible methods
of analysis that follow the paper method
section are given as a tutorial
so to get started with these we organize
a
getting started or introduction to
bioinformatics curriculum that anyone
can try
use for themselves or utilize for their
training and introduction to students
that don't have
even the basics of bioinformatics
as of now
so the introduction to bioinformatics
consists of
several different modules they're all
organized under this getting started
section
and they include introduction to
bioinformatics which is a course that
speaks about the applications of
bioinformatics in different domains like
healthcare pharmaceutical industry basic
and translational research environmental
research and others
it also covers the basic terminology
that connects biological concepts and
data science concepts or information
technology concepts in a course that we
call bytes and molecules so the course
is designed to introduce terminology and
the basic concepts that one has to know
to be able to continue and pursue
bioinformatics or computational biology
as a practical skill
and then we offered two simple courses
in bioinformatics and r and
bioinformatics in python that are
designed to
show how easy it is to start with coding
for someone that has minimal or no
background at all in coding and
has
some immediate applications to the types
of challenges that one might face
dealing with biological data
now apart from that we will talk today
about several other resources that we
utilize inside this training that help
build the logic of analysis
focused on big data
so we are
following this
specific
two directional approach one direction
is practical skills and those include
concepts terminology understanding
critical thinking and then we also
introduce this other dimension which is
the logic of analysis and how to apply
some of these concepts to large data
sets that typically you would not be
able to handle on your own on your own
system and so those technical
limitations are eliminated on our tbi
info platform that i'll discuss in a
moment
importantly like i mentioned all of
these topics are introduced in the
context of projects right because one of
the things that we realized is that it's
very difficult for somebody who's
interested let's say in infectious and
communicable diseases to understand the
specific applications of bioinformatics
in a context that is completely
different let's say in environmental
data or
maybe cancer data right so we want to
make those applications as closely
related to the type of interest that the
student might already have and so we
organize our
different tutorials under projects and
those projects could be divided into
different sections so what we
started with this year
is offering six
basic training modules and these six
basic training modules are introduction
to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and data science so these are offered as
year-long
curricula that you can organize into an
asynchronous or a live
type course
our team supports it and actually runs a
number of these programs throughout the
year and dr mazumder will be speaking
about some of these programs when i'm
done with my part of the presentation
[Music]
in addition to that
we also provide specialization tracks
and these include oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience and agriculture
and agriculture includes also some
elements of biotechnology
so what we
are trying to do is develop exemplar
projects with curated data sets and an
explanation of methods that are sourced
from
impactful publications in that domain
to illustrate how some of those basic
data types as well as methods could be
applied to solve real research
challenges
now let me briefly explain what is the
difference between what i am describing
as a curriculum or as a content database
and some of the practical resources that
are included in this program and in this
training
so the omixlogic program resources are
really designed around
training materials
computational tools that are easy to use
that biologists can use
interactive coding exercises that could
be first of all checked for syntax and
second of all checked for the correct
results and then finally an introduction
to a coding environment where you can
take some of the scripts that you've
learned how to write and then execute
them on a big data infrastructure
so let me briefly introduce some of
these resources in greater detail
one resource that is very critical for a
biologist to get started
is no code bioinformatics and that means
that you can use bioinformatics without
writing a single line of code
and for that purpose we have a big data
analysis platform that is uh not unlike
galaxy and some of the other tools that
exist out there but it is tightly
integrated with the curriculum that we
have designed for different types of
data and i'll briefly show this platform
today so that you can all get a sense of
what it really looks like and how it
works
the second part of this tutorial
approach is incorporating data science
and that means coding exercises that
check your ability to write correct
syntax without errors
and provide you with specific results to
the coding challenges so that you can
understand how to get the desired
outcome in your code following a
tutorial
and then finally we also are building a
network of mentors
that can help you take those skills
further and so essentially by working on
exemplary projects and trying to
identify research questions that could
be answered with data analysis skills we
can then eventually match you to a
research experience in which you can try
to understand a topic with the help of a
mentor that will eliminate some of the
dead ends and guide you to identify a
low-hanging fruit in terms of being able
to answer a research question as an
experience for you to gain computational
biology research skills
let me briefly
show you the resource that i mentioned
before so
right here if you go under courses
on the portal and by now i hope that
most of you have already created an
account i saw that some people joined
maybe a little bit late so i'll just
remind everyone this is a portal that we
are speaking about called omixlogix so
you can log in by following the link
learn.omixlogic.com
login is free you can gain access to
most of the resources for free and if
you are a part of one of our programs
through the nepi the national
association of idea principal
investigators you can gain access to all
of the resources that are mentioning
today for free using the nepe contract
that our company has
so here you will find
different types of courses materials and
projects
right here you will find different tags
that you can try
and below are
collections that you can find focused on
different types of data different types
of skills
and one of those skills is the tbion for
platform that really establishes the
logic of analysis
applicable to big data
so what is this platform
this platform and by the way anyone that
wants to demo account on this platform
after you have registered on the learn
portal and you have received your
password in your email
after 24 hours you will gain automatic
access to this platform
just to explore and see what it can do
so this platform is organized according
to several different sections you can
see here transcriptomics genomics
epigenomics
and different methods of analysis listed
on
this side
there's also sections related to mass
spectroscopy and structural biology
there are specific sections in
application to cancer biology single
cell analysis virology as well as data
integration and modeling so as you
look through these different sections
you'll find that some of them have a
drop down button
and this drop down button gives you
access to a demo pipeline builder that
you can try without having to upload any
data and without having to perform the
actual analysis so here for example you
will find that informative pop-ups that
are associated with each step of the
analysis will guide you
to build meaningful combinations of
scripts and algorithms
that will produce results that you can
use so for example in this
transcriptomics section you can see that
i can perform mapping using bow tie and
then visualize the sam file
of the mapping that i performed and in
addition to this visualization i can
also find resources on the learn portal
that will allow me to
to understand what exactly i am trying
to do so this is just an example again
you can see that in many sections
there's a drop down that you can find
different types of
different types of
you know methods of analysis and
different types of pipelines
that you can perform
so you can try and use that demo account
once you have created a login
so again that could be found
using coursework on t bioinfo and you
can see here a collection of courses
that you can explore and really learn
how to perform analysis of metagenomic
genomic transcriptomic and other types
of data
now to illustrate how these kinds of
methods are used in a
in a training
experience i want to briefly talk about
several different types of programs that
we run throughout the year and then i
will pass it on to dr mizunder to speak
about specific programs that we have
running right now starting in the end of
january
so a good example of a program that we
regularly run is a program on
transcriptomic data analysis and so we
call this bulk and single cell
transcriptomics
the program is designed to introduce the
omix technologies including how the
library preparation happens how the
actual sequencing happens how does the
understanding of the methods of data
preparation
impact our analysis approaches to that
data and
ultimately how to then use some of this
methodology to actually be able to
perform large scale
analysis using
these kinds of methods so
again starting from the t-bone for
platform that you just saw
we will
go through some example pipelines that
students build
they build those pipelines to understand
the inputs and the outputs behind each
step as well as the logic of analysis
how can they apply
the right combination of scripts and
methods to achieve the desired results
and all of it is very intuitive right as
you can see there's no coding involved
in addition to that the platform is
color coded and this color coding
follows a logic that we explain in
detail throughout the training program
itself
to apply those methods we then introduce
several different projects for example
cancer macrophages modeling cancer
precision medicine pdx tumor in the
micro environment but also
elements of infectious diseases like
malaria infection or even applications
in biotechnology and agriculture like
potato drought resistance for modified
crops
so that gives you an understanding of
the specific skills or specific methods
that need to be used and the specific
applications where you can actually try
and run that kind of analysis and see
what are the results what type of
insights you can generate analyzing such
data
in addition to that we then go on to one
of the you know
maybe most exciting areas of
transcriptomic data analysis which is
single cell rna-seq analysis and we also
have a very basic processing pipeline
as well as a downstream analysis
pipeline for sailrat and monocle that we
go from the logic and then apply
all of the logic in terms of code that
could be run on google cloud platform
using google colab
so what happens is that you understand
the logic the need and the reason for
specific methods and then you can apply
the specific portions of that code to
try and modify and get the types of
figures that you might need for a
publication
moreover you will then see how the exact
same approaches are used in high impact
publications that are
really transforming our understanding of
different domains
from cancer to neuroscience using such
techniques
so again
the objective in such a program in such
a basic program
is to introduce
the specific type of data
the methods that are typically used to
analyze such data and then showcase some
of the
applications of that data analysis
including multi-omics integration
another type of a program that i want to
briefly speak about is bioinformatics
for infectious diseases so one of the
things that really happened over the
past couple of years is that even people
who had no understanding of you know
mutations variants uh evolution and and
things like that really now know this
terminology and are even interested to
try and you know ask questions about the
huge amounts of publicly available data
related to the pandemic but also as an
extension of that related to many other
types of
epidemics or outbreaks that could be
occurring and so what we did is a couple
of years ago we worked with the
virologists here at the louisiana state
university
understood how their expertise in
virology and bioinformatics could be
used for
creating these training modules and then
continued our collaborations with
researchers at ucsf stanford louisiana
state university georgetown medical
center as well as other regional centers
for example a large research consortium
on malaria to create project examples
that illustrate how similar types of
analytical methods could be applied to
analyze data and understand these
outbreaks of infectious diseases
so in this program we use project
examples related to the enterovirus evd
68 which was an outbreak that affects
primarily younger children and happening
recently in europe as well as in the u.s
malaria infection uh again endemic in
africa but also in many regions of
south america i believe and in asia
sarskoff ii which we all are continuing
to observe as well as the ebola virus
epidemic that not only started the first
public and connected collection of next
generation sequencing data that is
publicly available but also produced
solid results including vaccines and
antiviral drugs that treated a disease
that was 90
deadly before that
so as an extension of that we also offer
a focused analysis of source cove 2 as a
training module that many of the
research institutions that we work with
can use immediately because
a big part of the
sequencing and
big part of the research questions
around sarskoff 2
are regional
and so by working with institutions like
louisiana state university where we did
many different projects on source codes
too including wastewater sequencing
we can train uh you know students and
researchers to be able to perform the
same and ask questions of the publicly
available data and so
on the learn portal that you have just
seen
you will see this kind of an overview
that gives the basics of multiple
sequence alignment as well as the
ability to ask questions about origins
of source code 2 or how the new variants
are emerging and how they might affect
the future of this pandemic
so at this point i briefly want to
introduce another element that i think
is critical for those students that are
serious about their interest in
bioinformatics
and what we see
time and time again is that
students going through short-term
training
are unable to capture a lot of the
aspects of
bioinformatics the application of
bioinformatics but also the ability to
independently
learn and continue to apply
bioinformatics once those resources are
unavailable
and so for that reason we wanted to make
sure that many of the same methods that
are available through such training
could be taken away with the researcher
or the student after the program
completion and they're able to replicate
and even use those in their um
you know reporting or
ability to analyze data and so i briefly
want to show you a course that is
designed to kind of give you a broad
understanding of how this portal works
and that will be introduction to
bioinformatics so if you go to
introduction to bioinformatics
sorry
bytes and molecules is what i wanted to
say okay so bytes and molecules
the bytes and molecules course
really covers many of the aspects of
what we just discussed for someone who
is a beginner and has minimum or no
background in bioinformatics wants to
understand the terminology that is used
in such training and wants to be
prepared with some of the technical
skills that are going to be needed
and one of the courses that will be
available in this
section is an introduction to coding
so coding
is an important part of a
bioinformatician's
you know day-to-day life and activity
but it is often seen as an exclusive
skill set that only bioinformaticians
and engineers really need to have but as
we all know in many aspects of research
just to produce the picture that you
need the figure
maybe some simple data analysis with
some statistical properties it is always
useful to be able to
know that piece of code that if you know
how to run it you know how to give it
the right input you can make it produce
the right output that you want and that
is exactly the objective of some of this
very basic introductory training that we
offer in this section called
introduction to bioinformatics languages
and this one is an example using r
so here you will find some very basic
things that you need to understand about
data how it is stored and how it is used
in the coding environment but we don't
have to set up a whole environment on
your own system to be able to run and
produce even the basic plots that you
might want to use in your research
publications or exploratory analysis of
a data set that could be very
informative
so we offer here
inside the actual lesson a console that
you can run
and get result
right here and as you can see
immediately if i just run this piece of
code i am getting an error
and the reason is because obviously this
path to the file does not work right and
so one of the basic challenges that all
of us probably faced when we started
learning how to code i can learn how to
write hello world but how do i actually
make this code work for my data right
and that's exactly where we start so
just by copying this link
and replacing it right here in the
console
i can run the code
and i can get some results right and so
right here you can see that
i can check the result
and now i have a successful result right
so i need to learn about some of the
syntax just some basics of writing how
to code i need to understand the logic
of how to find the right data and give
it the right link and then once i do
this console will check for me whether
i'm doing the right thing and now i can
extend this to more advanced
applications like running a script to
prepare a box plot or maybe
changing the way that this figure looks
right and eventually i will be
introduced to a an assignment and that
assignment will be right writing a
complete piece of code right so if i
know that i can complete this assignment
i'm not only following a step-by-step
tutorial but i'm in fact able to apply
what i have learned and now i can copy
this
and use it on my system to be able to
run that every time i face a result
so what kinds of activities are possible
for this type of uh learning
one of the training that we do in terms
of source code 2 is performing multiple
sequence alignment and phylodynamics
of the pandemic outbreak in different
regions to really understand the
emerging variants or clades that have
been reported throughout the course of
the pandemic so as you can see the logic
of analysis is first done on the
platform
and then we actually go through a series
of steps to generate a variant report
and this is a report not unlike what
people use when they use clinical
reporting or or when that reporting is
being submitted to
you know maybe public health
institutions to understand whether there
is a particular variant of concern
or maybe there are some number of
samples that you know indicate that
there's a spread of that bearing of
concern so we go through preparing such
a report
in r how to install all of the different
tools that are needed on your own system
and then how to actually run that with
the specific types of variants that you
might be interested in so it really
provides an ability to apply the logic
try it on publicly available data and
potentially then
apply the same to novel data that is
being collected now we don't stay at the
sequence level we also try to
incorporate the association between
sequence and the structure so we look at
the spike protein we understand the
spike protein and even map the mutations
and understand the relationship between
the proteins so that we understand how
they are interacting and as a result
understand the significance of some of
those variants and all of that is done
in under a month-long training program
now another big part of what we do
going beyond the traditional
bioinformatics where we deal a lot with
sequence data and visualization is
actually learn about data science and
for data science we have this very basic
introduction that i just showed you in r
and python but we also want to be able
to apply some of those methods of
exploratory data analysis statistical
analysis machine learning in a more
advanced environment and so we created
this program to offer um you know
greater insights into what is possible
just knowing some of those basics
again this is project oriented so we
start with
seemingly simple challenges for example
in the context of precision medicine can
we identify a patient that is likely to
respond or not respond to a particular
type of
medication
and then we use that information to be
able to explain some of the additional
downstream requirements for dealing with
bigger data how you can use different
packages how you can produce advanced
visualizations how you can apply similar
approaches to different types of data be
it genomic metagenomic transcriptomic
and others and eventually how to also
apply this using machine learning
you know advanced statistical analysis
and an understanding of how to apply
these skills to bigger data sets
now we've recently completed a program
like this that was you you know all of
it was designed around python
from very basics
to more and more advanced types of
applications where we also highlighted
the significance of an online
cloud-based environment to be able to
write reproducible code and i think
those are two very important trends that
students need to be introduced to
as they move into the application of
bioinformatics or data science to
particular types of research not only do
we need to be able to extract meaningful
insights we also need to know how we got
those insights and provide an
environment where others can easily
reproduce the same code that we write
which means that the code needs to be
readable which means that we need to
explain what we're doing and why we're
doing that and also highlight the
results
with a piece of code that somebody can
take and
run and and get the exact same thing and
so there we cover things like you know
dimensionality reduction
ordination and embedding
we look at
different types of classification models
including the understanding of how those
models work and how principles of those
logistic regression for example methods
are used in
more advanced methods like deep learning
and also
connect that with again practical
examples and those practical examples
could be used for
projects that have made a significant
impact so after we cover this domain of
machine learning we actually take a look
at several different publications where
all of the methods that we cover are
explained in the abstract itself and the
student can really see and appreciate
how the
specific outcome from some research
really affected
the
industry or even the clinical use of
those methods so for example here
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer is a project that we use to
illustrate individualized and
personalized treatment as well as
predictive modeling to understand
potential response that does not require
data from that patient themselves over a
course of different types of treatments
right which is obviously not possible
and i think very relevant to the medical
field which is moving further and
further into the adoption of such tools
and the precision treatment of
different types of complex diseases
now
beyond this training and i'll i'll be
done here in a couple of minutes
we offer to use the same elements that
i've just described the t-bone for
platform for no code bioinformatics the
coding elements that you can embed right
into your coursework your expertise in
projects by illustrating a specific type
of a method in application to a data set
that you understand and might have
published before
as a resource for researchers and
faculty that would like to incorporate
their own training and make it available
to the nepu network so one of the ideas
is to
identify gaps
for example if you take an institution
that might not have a full
bioinformatics
core and they might not have the
you know facilities to be able to
support bioinformatics and computational
biology research
we would like to match them with another
institution that might have those
capabilities but might be lacking
another capability that that university
does have and so by linking those we're
able to address the gap across the whole
network
one example that i would like to show is
a course that we designed together with
dr sono vasudevan
she is the program director at the
georgetown university medical center for
a program called systems medicine and
her special is her specialty is in
bioinformatics using uh 3d protein
structures and really uh uh kind of
looking at the relationship between
sequence and structure and so we worked
with her to create a summer course
where her students and students from
other uh backgrounds could join and and
learn the basics of genomics in the
virtual lab
we also worked with researchers that
specialize in oncology
developing a program on precision
oncology and
we also kind of design these together in
collaboration with other researchers and
faculty and we are hoping to expand our
network and really uh kind of build the
same model of
the context the methodology and examples
of applications using curated data sets
to expand the library of resources that
we're offering
now we've done these programs over the
year the several years now
in several different institutions
we do have a lot of kind of feedback
from different users including students
faculty researchers and we are starting
to work with industry as well not only
to provide the basic training
and the path to research but also for
students that are interested in a path
to an industry career right where
bioinformatics is a highly desired
profession and skill set and can really
make a difference in someone pursuing
that direction
so thank you again for listening to my
part of the presentation
it took a little bit longer than i
anticipated but i would like to pass
this on to dr mohit mizunder who will
speak about some of our ongoing programs
that we
have started in january
and are now available uh to the nepe
community for free throughout 2022
thank you india and hello everyone it's
it's an absolute pleasure to meet you
all
um so uh today
i'm going to talk about the
opportunities and i think many of you
would be interested to learn about those
opportunities upcoming opportunities
that you can
that you can participate in so is my
screen visible to all of you
yes
it is
okay so um thank you for that detailed
overview india and uh i think um uh what
we were trying to do is also to simplify
this entire um training
using uh modular tools and intuitive
material mix platform that you just saw
we are working with the students and
researchers and we are providing
research support and also big data
analytics tools designed for biomedical
data discovery ultimately we are working
for a future where we where we can
contribute to enhance human health and
well-being through biological research
and discovery with the data solutions
and support and uh like as i as you
already saw in this during this
presentation what we're trying to do is
that we're trying to close the gap
between for research and discovery by
utilizing skills uh that that have been
developed throughout this training
period uh with different training
programs that are designed specifically
uh to achieve some of the meaningful
outcomes that we are highlighting
along with the application learning
about the application of these different
uh
new areas of research
so um
all of this starts with very basic so
it's it's uh very simple it's just that
we start from very basic uh coursework
then we learn about these different data
types and then uh at the same time we
learn about how machine learning or data
science or
programming languages plays a role in
downstream analysis and creating you
know better visualization and all of
that so this is the basic training that
we offer along with that there is a lot
of project project examples so this is
where it gets really interesting when
you are being able to you know apply
this these uh
learning into some real hands-on data
sets do some real hands-on exercises
learn about through the practical
examples so here i did talk about all of
this uh many of these in quite detail
and i i i hope that you have gotten
understanding and please feel free to
write in that chat if you have if you
have any questions uh throughout the
presentation that you want to clarify
and uh
again about the structure first of all
we are learning about the basic we are
learning about the different data
analysis
different data types and
their analysis then we are learning
through example projects and then we are
trying to work on these specialization
track projects so these are high value
research questions that we would want to
answer in collaboration with the faculty
of collaboration with a student
or a group
so about the steps uh these are the
different steps that we have very simple
introduction then some specialization
and some
examples to learn about the
specialization and then to be able to
work on the specialization and now i
would like to tell you about the
upcoming opportunity that we've been
mentioning with the nappy network and
with lvrn and lsu so we are piloting uh
we are not piloting we are just doing
the spring programs as we are doing
spring programs and summer programs
really some exciting bunch of programs
that helps uh uh many to start their
bioinformatics journey to develop these
different type of skill sets so we have
different levels here beginners levels
level intermediate level and advanced
level so these programs will be
available for many of you who would be
interested to joining this
these pro these uh mentor guided
programs so you can also see in this
slide that there are a few dates that uh
put together but we will go to the pages
the individual pages where we have put
together all the information including
the syllabus
the dates that have the asynchronous
material that will be shared so it has a
combination of different elements as you
as you could see in in the previous
presentation by ilia he discussed about
the courses
we discussed about i showed you the
project examples so these have
combination of all these resources uh
put together as very innovative
syllabuses uh in a meaningful way that
lead you from basic training to
different specialized training and to be
able to you know
start working on real data sets so uh to
tell you about the first program
introduction to bioinformatics is just
to get you started with bioinformatics
this online training is designed for
everyone including students who do not
have any background in bioinformatics so
we will learn in this program we will
get an overview and learn about the
processing sections such as genomics
transcriptomics for analyzing and
interpreting omics data and that will be
followed by uh using machine learning
technology uh techniques to interpret uh
more
insights from this data so this is a
basic program that would help many
to get started and in this
program we will also cover
various public repositories so how to
find data uh what are the different file
formats that are
that have application in biological
research
and then it would be concluded by
annotation visualization and
interpretation of the results so uh the
entire uh concept and the entire idea
with this program is to get everyone
started give them an overview of
different sections that are available on
the tbi info platform that you saw
along with that
with every session we will have
asynchronous material so there will be
course coursework associated with it so
bytes and molecules and bytes and
molecules and introduction to
bioinformatics course then getting
started with bioinformatics then are
getting started with bioinformatics and
python and there are then nine case
studies that we will cover uh during
this
program
now i'll go into much more detail about
each of these programs and i'll show you
that
we have put together these pages that
you can check and see the dates
for your availability that uh
that uh that will help you decide to
join the program and get trained and uh
also like um
these will be done uh through a mixture
like a hybrid program there will be
asynchronous sessions most of the
sessions ability asynchronous we will be
where we will be sharing with you a
video and
the online material as well as the
assignments and all the
collab notebooks and all of that that
elia was just showing you but here are
some dates the
where we will have live sessions and uh
these will be
at uh 1 pm cst time
but i'll i'll again we'll go to that
in the next few slides but before that
let me also tell you about the data
science program so in the data science
program which is again would be
uh we will be using
uh uh python and our
and we will learn throughout this course
student will get an understanding of
opportunities and limitations of machine
learning in the context of pre-clinical
and clinical research this course is
designed as a combination of online
resources as well as the practical
assignments and the live workshops so
all of these omics logic programs have
these elements
and in this uh throughout this course we
will review several project examples
that demonstrates the successes and
limitations of conventional machine
learning methods and deep learning and
we will be using a lot of
data sets that we have prepared for you
to go through and understand and
understand like the challenges that we
see
when we use these methods not only just
uh to learn about the application but
what are the real challenges that you
face when you start analyzing your own
data which is something that is not
covered otherwise so this will have a
lot of sessions from future selection
gene uh gene signature construction to
regression and generalized linear models
network analysis uh and as i said deep
learning and then
um
learning bioml
and doing the course work as well so
there will be also a special coursework
specialized coursework associated with
the data science program then we also
have you opportunity for you to join um
these programs the basic data types
which is like to learn about genomic
analysis if you're working on genomic
data or if you have an interest in
working in genomic data then in this
genomic program we will cover ngs
genomics so we will go through sanger
and wes and wgs and then we will learn
about the dna code and the copy number
variations then we will learn about the
genomic sequence alignment and analysis
and we will try to visualize them uh
through different browsers and popular
tools that are available not only
through the t bind for platform but the
free uh publicly available resources
then we will learn how to analyze
genomic data using art and then we will
work on um
different pipelines that we have put
together like uh
genome white association studies that
which will which and again there will be
a lot of case studies here we will uh
discuss special case studies from cancer
infectious diseases and agriculture so
that would be about the genomics and
then there's an also an opportunity to
do metagenomic data analysis to learn
about metagenomic data analysis which is
really a com field that is coming up and
showing us those different type of
associations that we were not even
looking before so learning about the
microbiome the
functional bacterial community 16s rrna
metagenomic sequencing ribosomal rna
hyper variable regions operational tax
economic units i'm just discussing about
the keywords because uh you will have an
opportunity to learn about all of them
in much more depth throughout these
programs and also to do not only just
learn about it but also practice this
and you know run pipelines like uh climb
kind to uh data data two pipeline for
amp amplicon sequencing then we will
look into the sra and hmp and american
gut uh american gut project human gut
project perhaps the viral genome
detection through you know metagenomic
data uh looking at the evolution of
fitness or quasi quasi species uh all of
those things are
kind of covered in this
we also look into the brain gut excess
and how the gut microbiome affects uh by
diet and the effect of you know
fertilizers
to drug resistance all those
interesting projects are covered and
you know research ideas are being
discussed in this uh metagenomic program
so that is a brief overview of all the
upcoming opportunities that that all of
you have an opportunity to join uh and
i'll tell you more about these uh
these programs
sorry um so because it is almost time uh
for this session
maybe you could
tell about the registration process yeah
could you just paste the links in chat
as well
right so this is the link uh or jesse
has already shared i'll request registry
to again maybe share this link so uh
please go to this link and you can fill
this form that you can see on the screen
and choose the program that you're
interested in if you're interested to
join multiple programs then you can
obviously check two check boxes but we
will recommend you to
do as per your availability um so you
have options to
check uh these uh um
fill this form and our team will reach
out to you with the
all the information that we have
discussed in this meeting and all the
links that we have been discussing we
will also share these links to uh with
luis and i hope that luis can also
maybe uh help in sharing those links
with
the students who are interested in the
faculty who are interested but if you
reach out if you can fill out this form
in this page on nippy.org training
resources and the second page then we
will be able to uh
send you the details via email also so
please look for our emails many times
this end up in spam or different uh
filters uh so please uh do check for
with some of these keywords and you'll
be able to see the uh find the email in
your
inbox and
you will be able to learn and get all
the links that are required and we will
be sharing with you the meeting links
once you registered so you will get
access to different resources that we
discussed today and followed by this
these courses uh one of the purpose of
doing this is again to be able to learn
about these different type of data types
and then uh to be able to work on a
research project so in the summer we
will be doing uh the research will be uh
we will be uh
providing opportunity to all of you to
work on your own research proposals uh
that would be high value research
questions that you uh that you already
are maybe working on or that a question
that you would be uh you know um
proposing after the training that
happens quite often many students go
through this entire process and propose
really amazing questions that could be
uh easily uh
[Music]
that you can easily uh
learn about or maybe thought about when
you go through the data sets explore the
data sets go through the publication
there are several ideas that keeps on
coming that one would be interested to
explore so that opportunity would be
available in the summer through the
research fellowship program and again uh
this program will have certain um
objectives that we would want to
showcase as an outcome to be able to get
a poster presentation to be able to
showcase in different uh
different uh conferences and to be able
to publish also so we also have a
coursework associated with that and we
have several of these case studies and
uh previous students who have been able
to complete uh
through this research fellowship program
and showcase their results and publish
their results so all of this opportunity
could be also through this omixologic
research symposium where we are bringing
together students
faculty researchers and industry to
discuss about recent advancements in
omics data and bioinformatics there will
be a poster session there will be uh
prizes uh there will be uh
internship and career opportunities
those all those things will be discussed
in the research symposium so we will be
glad if you many of you could also join
this research symposium which will be
freely available to all of you who are
interested so uh that is what we uh kind
of planned today to show all of you then
we have a lot of research collaborations
where we are working with different
organizations who are providing us with
mentors and additional support that
would be helpful for many researchers
who would envision collaboration uh in
the future and similarly
as i said that these are our spring
programs followed by that we have our
summer programs where we have all these
interesting programs coming up for you
to take in the summer once you complete
uh your basic training and you'll be
more uh
interested and
a little more relevant for you all of
you so thank you all for your time and
i'll now pass it on to ilya to conclude
the session
thank you yes i want to address some of
the questions that i see here in the
chat but before we do that i know that
it's the end of the session i see some
people nicole
pasting some evaluation links i don't
know if you want to
speak about that or jose did you want to
say anything
okay so um
there were two questions that i saw in
the chat one of them is
to speak about what kind of
uh data will you be able to access from
your students let's say if you offer
this as a special topics course
so in fact many people start with a
special topics one credit course
to give an overview
and
what we provide is all of the activity
data uh for those students so i'll just
uh
i already showed the profile but uh
briefly
you will be able to see
all of the activity
uh which for example uh goes on to show
what kind of assignments have been
completed
uh what are the specific issues that the
person faced and all of this across the
whole time so you can actually go and
check what was covered in that
particular lesson so there's a lot of
activity and all of this activity feeds
into
the types of courses that are completed
what those courses covered
as well as certificates for any of the
coursework that were completed fully
that will also be available so as a
faculty you will have access to all of
your student data
so that was question number one question
number two that i see do you offer
special assistance in your courses for
mac users
i'm a mac user so you can see
here we have everything designed around
online tools first of all so as much as
possible we try to avoid any of the
technical limitations of different
systems and configurations that is
typically what any trainer would spend
45 percent of their time is
troubleshooting
and that's why we try to put as much as
possible online after that we provide
specific tutorials on how to install and
configure your environment for mac users
for windows users for linux users as
well so if you have any specific
questions
we can definitely help you with that
i think those were all the questions one
important thing that i want to clarify
is that all of these programs are
available for free
for those that are members of nepi the
way we count members of nepi is if you
are at a university or a research lab
that is somehow funded through the idea
program uh then that makes it a part of
nepi
and so if you can specify that in your
application um that would help us kind
of match you with that account
thank you everyone for inviting us uh
and we hope to see you all again
in the training that is coming up and
i'll pass this on to jose
dr thank you
and also uh dr mozunder thank you very
much
for this very interesting orientation
informative seminar i think we have lots
of things to talk about
uh and follow up on and i want to uh
ask our our public uh
we have uh uh
remaining in the chat 35 participants i
want to let them know that
these uh orientations will also be uh
repeated in some of our other
uh network institutions uh luis asked me
to mention that uh some of the anaheim
mendes institutions will be hosting this
uh
this orientation so if you if you didn't
get the full
uh or you uh presentation or if you want
to just get a repeat to you can log on
to the
p-r-i-n-b-r-e puerto rico imbre uh just
google
p-r-i-n-b-r-e and you'll find uh
uh the uh information uh for the next uh
orientation here in puerto rico
so uh thank you so much and uh
we look forward to interesting
collaborations with pine biotech
in the future
thank you very much and again thank you
for inviting us and we will continue to
look out for those of you that decide to
participate thank you
okay have a great afternoon thank you
everyone for attending and it's time to
sign out now also
uh we'll see you soon in the next uh
seminars